عن جلسه هذا اليوم نذهب الى لهاي الى محمد
البقالي محمد اجرائيا ما الذي سيتم في هذا
اليوم المح
وهو هذا اليوم عبد القادر سيتم الاستماع
الى مرافعات جنوب افريقيا وكما سمعنا
وشاهدنا طه هذا اليوم الفريق القانوني
لجنوب افريقيا يتقدمه وزير العدل ركز على
ثلاث نقاط رئيسيه المساله الاولى على
الاسباب القانونيه لرفع هذه الدعوه والامر
يتعلق باتفاقيه منع الاباده الجماعيه التي
تم التوقيع عليها عام
1948 واسرائيل ضمن الموقعين عليها
وبالتالي فيجعل هذه الدعوه ذات مقبول امام
المحكمه ويجعل المحكمه مستعد للبث في هذه
القضيه ثم بعد ذلك تحدثت عن الاسباب
الفعليه لرفع هذه الدعوه من خلال جرد ما
يحصل في غزه طبعا استمعنا الى كثير من
التفاصيل وهذه التفاصيل التي نشاهدها في
الحقيقه بالصوت والصوره وبشكل مباشر من
خلال الجرائم المرتكبه في غزه سواء والتي
تقع تحت طائله القانون لان النقاش هنا هو
نقاش قانوني صرف ليس فيه مجال للانطباع
ولا مجال
للسياسه الفريق القانوني لجنوب افريقيا
وضع هذه الافعال التي تقوم بها اسرائيل
تحت طائله اتفاقيه عام 1948 لمنع الاباده
الجماعيه وقال انها فعلا تخرق هذه
الاتفاقيه واعطى ل لذلك امثله كثيره من
خلال القصف بدون تمييز عدد الضحايا الكبير
الذي يؤكد نيه الاباده استهداف القطاع
الصحي الحصار المطبق التجويع منع الماء
وغير ذلك من التفاصيل الكثيره والطويله
التي استمعنا اليها والتي كلها تؤكد ان
اسرائيل بالفعل تقع قانونيا تحت طائله خرق
اتفاقيه منع الاباده التي وقعت عليها ثم
الجانب الثالث الذي تركز عليه او يركز
عليه الفريق القانوني لجنوب افريقيا هو
مستوى التصريحات اي ان هذه الافعال التي
تقوم بها اسرائيل لم تاتي بمحض الممارسه
الميدانيه الصرفه او ربما نتيجه الاعمال
القتاليه وانما وراءها نيه مبيته تشهد
عليها تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
وهنا
تم الاستشهاد بالتصريحات التي بدات
تصريحات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين منذ
السابع من اكتوبر بدا من تصريحات رئيس
الوزراء مرورا بالتصريحات التي تصريحات
وزير الدفاع وتصريحات مسؤولين وزير الامن
وغيرهم الذين هددوا منذ البدايه واعلنوا
انهم سيدمرون غزه ومنهم من وصف سكان غزه ب
الحيوانات وغير ذلك مما يؤكد بان قانونيا
وهنا دائما الحديث على المستوى القانوني
ان هذه الافعال التي تقع في غزه ترافقها
نيه مبيته وبالتالي عبد القادر اليوم
سيستمر الاستماع للفريق القانوني لجنوب
افريقيا غدا سيتم الاستماع لدفعات التي
ستتقدم بها اسرائيل بعد ذلك ستجتمع ستخرج
المحكمه للتداول لمده قصيره يتوقع قبل
نهايه هذا الشهر ان تصدر قرارها مع
الاشاره عبد القادر الى ان القرار الذي
سيصدره هذه المره او بشكل مستعجل هو يدخل
ضمن ما يسمى بالقرارات الاستعجال او
القرارات الوقائيه المؤقته وفيها تطالب
جنوب افريقيا المحكمه باصدار امر لاسرائيل
بان توقف اعمالها العسكريه لانها تندرج
ضمن الاباده الانسانيه وبالتالي
فالمحكمة ان تصدر امرا لاسرائيل يامرها
بوقف الاعمال القتاليه او ربما يامرها
بالسماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه او غير
ذلك من الاوامر التي قد تصدرها المحكمه
لاسرائيل وهي اوامر ملزمه ومستعجله بعد
ذلك ستجتمع المحكمه ربما للبث في جوهر
الدعوه جوهر الدعوه هل يتعلق الامر بموضوع
الاباده هذا يتطلب سنوات ولكن ما هو
مستعجل الان ويفترض ان يصدر على الارجح
قبل نهايه هذا الشهر هو القرار الذي يتعلق
بالاجراءات الاستثنائيه والتي تطلب فيه
جنوب افريقيا من المحكمه ان تصدر امرا
لاسرائيل بان توقف هذه الحرب لانها تخرق
التزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه منع الاباده
الجماعيه ان حدث هذا الامر فان اسرائيل
ستجد نفسها في موقف قانوني صعب جدا لان
قرارات المحكمه هي قرارات ملزمه ويمكن ان
نقول ان هذه المحاكمه هي محاكمه تاريخيه
عبد قادر لانه مرات قليله اجتمعت المحكمه
في تاريخها للبث في قضايا مثل هذه وهناك
رمزيه ايضا مكثفه عبد القادر بالنظر الى
ان الذي قدم الدعوه هي جنوب افريقيا جنوب
افريقيا التي عت منتاي من الفصل العنصري
وقدمت نفسها بالاضافه الى هذه الرمزيه
محمد على صعيد الشكل ايضا لفت الانتباه
وفد او الوفد القانوني لجنوب افريقيا من
يمثل هذا الوفد على صعيد الاسماء المتقدمه
في هذا الوفد بالاضافه الى ما قيل حتى قبل
هذه الجلسه بان ملف الملف المقدم من جنوب
افريقيا ملف ثقيل
قانونيا بالفعل بالفعل عبد القادر الملف
ثقيل على المستوى القانوني والادله التي
قدمت فيه في ا في
84 صفحه تتضمن على المستوى القانوني ادله
قويه من شانها على كل حال هذا ما يقوله
القانونيون ان تدفع المحكمه الى اتخاذ
قرار على هذا المستوى والمساله الرمزيه
دعني عبد القادر اعود اليها قالها الرئيس
الجنوب الافريقي بشكل واضح قال نحن بلد
عانى من الفصل العنصري وبالتالي فنحن ندعم
شعبا يعاني من هذا الفصل العنصري جنوب
افريقيا لديها هذه الرمزيه في الذاكره
الجماعيه للعالم وبالتالي فعندما تتقدم هي
بهذه الدعوه علاوه على ذلك بان جنوب
افريقيا لا ينظر اليها على انها دوله
تندرج ضمن المعسكر المناوئ للغرب وبالتالي
حتى الدول الغربيه الداعمه لاسرائيل تجد
نفسها في حرج كبير امام هذه الرمزيه وامام
اولا هذه الدعوه وامام ان تكون جنوب
افريقيا هي التي تقف وراء هذه الدعوه
بالنسبه للملف الذي تقدمت به جنوب افريقيا
هنا يمكن ان نعود عبد القادر الى الوابق
سوابق المحكمه خلال السنوات الثلاث
الماضيه المحكمه اصدرت حكمين يقضي بوقف
اعمال الاباده اولا في حق
مينمار او امرت مينمار بوقف اعمال الاباده
او اعمال القتل في حق مجموع الشعب
الروهينجا عام
2020 ثم بعد ذلك امرت روسيا عام
[موسيقى]
2021 او بعد بدايه عفوا بعد بدايه الحرب
وبعد رفع دعوه امام المحكمه امرت روسيا
بان توقف ما وصفتها باعمال الاباده الادله
التي قدمت في موضوع روسيا وفي موضوع
ميانمار كانت اقل مما قدم في موضوع غزه
وهذا ما يرجح بالنسبه لكثيرين ان القرار
سيكون لصالح فلسطين محمد البقالي ارجو ان
تبقى معنا في متابعه هذه الجلسه الاولى من